the last few years I've begun to wonder
if we're compatible anymore maybe this
doesn't
work anymore for me I don't know maybe
this is not a good fit maybe this
doesn't work Janelle and Cody's
relationship is on the rocks and
Janelle's even hinting their marriage
might be over I think there was a lot of
challenges and it played out in
in just as complicated way in our family
as it does in the bigger sphere it took
a lot of work for us to figure out how
to navigate it on Sister Wives the mom
of six has a heated argument with her
hubby about their relationship after
Cody implies he wants her to be more
like his fourth wife Robin I have
somebody in my life who is fundamentally
loyal to me
who sees me as the head of the family
I'm saying to you that you and I get
that if you're loyal to me
I can't I just can't believe
I just can't believe what he's saying
but that's not the only thing Cody
admits I'm pretty much a loose can and
I'm just a guy who just doesn't hold
back you and I have been acting like we
weren't a married couple for most of our
marriage Chanel
I don't know why it's been okay for so
many years and it's not now but you
actually live like a single woman or
maybe this is not a good fit maybe this
doesn't work
it feels like the rules have changed for
me a little bit despite all their
differences this is one thing Cody and
Janelle actually agree on I never
thought that I would ever be in a place
where I would be questioning my
relationship but the last few years I've
begun to wonder
if we're compatible anymore maybe this
doesn't
work anymore for me I don't know and get
this Janelle asked Cody this big
question I mean do you want the plural
family still
no I question it all the time I guess
well me too for me emotionally it's
sinking
the ship is sinking
but no if you can change the way our
relationship was for 30 years all of a
sudden
I mean maybe that's a sign that it just
doesn't work anymore but at the end of
the day she wants to make things work I
feel connected to you I mean you're my
best friend you're my lover everything
like I just I want to stay
maybe we figure it out maybe we don't I
still have so much affection for Cody I
hi I don't know if it's love
accordion I've definitely had challenges
this year because we've had to spend
more time apart than we have ever
probably so that's definitely been
something I've had to kind of really
think about and realize I still like him
and I still want him around so that was
kind of a nice and as Cody's told E.T
before he's not one to give up either
I'm not in place where I say hey to a
wife I'm leaving you that's just never
going to happen
uh it's just not you know if if our
relationship isn't good then we either
figure out how to work it out or or
whatever
foreign
[Music]